künstliche intelligenz ki macht immer
größere fortschritte und hält einzug in
unser tägliches leben noch sind die
anwendung punktuell und nicht perfekt
aber ki hat genau dazu das zeug sie kann
sich immer weiter selbst perfektionieren
und wir erfahren im zweifel noch nicht
mal wie sie das gemacht hat chance also
oder gefahr in europa werden jedenfalls
jetzt die ersten vorkehrungen für den
kampf gegen die künstliche intelligenz
getroffen wir freuen uns dieses thema
vom magazin pm mit exklusivem material
aus dem aktuellen heft übernehmen zu
können in zusammenarbeit mit dem magazin
gibt es übrigens auch noch einen hammer
gewinnspiel bei dem ihr diese dj willi
frey more combo kamera drohne gewinnen
könnt ihr das ding ich dreh zum beispiel
ab wozu mit ihrem großen bruder also
mega los geht's
herzlich willkommen und einen riesen
dank an pm das magazin pm ist mein
absolutes lieblings magazin weil es wie
wir komplexen themen einfach erklärt und
dabei auch heiße eisen anfasst wie hier
die künstliche intelligenz ki und die
umfassende recherche zu diesem thema
stammt von pm wenn die die es nicht mehr
erwarten können den hammerpreis in
augenschein zu nehmen der link zum
gewinnspiel ist hier unter mir und in
der video beschreibung und im ersten
angebunden kommentar wenn man sich da
weitergeht kommt man auch zu den genauen
teilnahmebedingungen
wir werden alle sterben okay das
passiert so oder so bei jedem von uns
früher oder später aber stephen hawking
und auch ihren mast haben vor der gefahr
durch ki gewarnt sie könne uns alle
umbringen maske sieht ganz konkret
marodierende roboter durch die straßen
ziehen auch wenn das vielleicht einen
hauch übertrieben ist die eu ist jetzt
dabei regelungen aufzustellen um die
künstliche intelligenz einzudämmen denn
sie ist tatsächlich potenziell
gefährlich eigentlich ist ganz simpel
und arbeitet wie unser gehirn und unser
gehirn ist ja zu absoluten
höchstleistungen in der lage für uns
sind sie ganz normal aber für mir ist
das ziemlich tricky was wir können und
so hat die entscheidende schritte erst
in den letzten zehn jahren gemacht
maschinelles lernen und riesige
rechenkapazitäten haben den großen
fortschritt ermöglicht und neue
prozessoren die für kai optimiert sind
wie zb in einem iphone oder einem tesla
denn programmiert wird ki nicht mehr von
unseren leistungsfähigen gehirnen von
menschlichen programmieren sondern von
computerprogrammen und die haben ein
ganz einfaches prinzip nach dem auch
unser gehirn funktioniert die learning
maschinelles lernen heute kann mein
iphone in den fotos gegenstände oder
sogar konkrete personen erkennen kann
beliebige texte lesen die ich
fotografiere oder auf die ich die kammer
richte in echtzeit in der astrophysik
kann ki in alten beobachtungsdaten neue
himmelskörper entdecken in der medizin
wird sie immer mehr eingesetzt um
krankheiten zu erkennen und so weiter
und so fort das haben sich die computer
selbst beigebracht per learning sie sind
auf die jeweiligen fähigkeiten
spezialisiert das ist also noch alles
sehr eingegrenzt wenn man sich
allerdings die beta-version für das
autonome fahren von tesla so ansieht
dann ist das absolut meint gläubigen
diese software kann nicht nur in fotos
sondern im stetigen video live feed von
acht kameras das absolut komplexe
szenario verkehr mit schildern menschen
straßen autos lkw und verhalten erkennen
und daraus handlung ableiten das zeigt
die wirklich unglaublichen möglichkeiten
der bund von die planning wie
funktioniert die planung also dazu
müssen wir uns nur selbst einmal vor
augen führen wie wir dinge erkennen oder
unterscheiden woran erkennen wir einen
gegenstand zum beispiel zum vergleich
ein buch und einen kugelschreiber
wir erkennen als erstes die form der
kugelschreiber ist lang und dünn das
buch ist auch lang und dünn aber dazu
breit der kugelschreiber hier hat einen
clip und eine mine die vorne als spitze
herauskommen kann das buch dagegen hat
so etwas nicht und stattdessen sind die
dünnen linien an der seite erkennbar und
der buchdeckel gibt sich etwas ab und es
sind noch dutzende weitere eigenschaften
die wir kennen im gehirn passiert das
schicht für schicht mit neuronen und den
synapsen die sie verbinden und die
jeweiligen eigenschaften gewichten
wichtige eigenschaften werden stark zum
nächsten neuron verbunden unwichtige
schwach und wenn wir einen weiteren
ähnlichen gegenstand kennenlernen müssen
wir wieder etwas verändern die neuronen
in unserem gehirn werden über diesen
achsen anders verbunden und dann wird an
einem apple pencil von erkannt dass er
keine miene hat und also nicht auf
papier schreiben kann und damit ein
eingabegerät in diesem fall von einem
ipad ist bei einem gegenstand werden mit
jeder neuen eigenschaft die neuronen
über diese nation anders verbunden und
das beginnt bei einzelnen pixeln die
dann langsam als strukturen
zusammengefügt und erkannt werden und so
weiter und so fort schicht für schicht
und genauso ist es bei die burning dieb
also tief ist es weil so viele schichten
daran beteiligt sind die die
verschiedenen eigenschaften eines
objekts erkennen und am ende des
prozesses das gesamte objekt einordnen
können hier in der grafik von pm ist es
perfekt dargestellt jede schicht
analysiert mehr eigenschaften und am
ende steht das ergebnis fest ein abflug
die menschen wissen warum wir diesen
rundlichen gegenstand als absolut
erkennen wir kennen genau die
eigenschaften die uns einen apfel
erkennen lassen bei ki haben wir davon
keine ahnung sie kann es mit diesem
verfahren mit jedem gegenstand wir
wissen aber nicht welche eigenschaften
die karrieren zieht um etwas zu erkennen
in deutschland hat man sich allerdings
nicht damit zufrieden gegeben und hat
erforscht wie ki entscheidung trifft und
hat die spektrale relevanz analyse
angewendet und das ist dann frappierend
rot sind die bereiche die für die
erkennung relevant sind und bei einem
zug waren es in diesem beispiel die
schienen die für die ki das wichtigste
erkennungsmerkmal für einen zug war das
heißt dass diese pixel von den
virtuellen synapsen im computer mit
hoher gewichtung zwischen den neuronen
transportiert werden sie sind das
wichtigste kriterium dafür einen zug und
da zeigt sich auch wie anfällig ki ist
denn was ist wenn keine schienen zu
sehen sind spannend der ki so auf die
finger gucken zu können kann also immer
mehr und mehr und das in immer mehr
bereichen in china werden mit ki und
gesichtserkennung menschen getrackt ihre
beziehungen und ihr verhalten wer sich
systemkonform verhält bekommt pluspunkte
wer nicht bekommt punktabzug und dann
auch konsequenzen man kann sich nicht
verstecken der staat weiß alles die
reisefreiheit wird dann eingeschränkt
und man kann zug oder flugtickets mehr
kaufen und das nicht weil man ein
verbrechen begangen hat sondern
lediglich weil man sich nicht
systemkonform verhalten hat auch in
deutschland wurde die gesichtserkennung
getestet am bahnhof südkreuz wurden
zwischen 2017 und 2018 gesichter
gescannt und mit datenbanken abgeglichen
die trefferquote lag hoch aber es wurden
auch viele fehler gemacht zu viele wie
manche fachleute meinen hier werden dann
nicht terroristen verdächtigt sondern
harmlose reisende aber selbst wenn das
system fehlerfrei arbeiten würde es kann
in den falschen händen missbraucht
werden antonio krüger ist chef des
deutschen forschungszentrums für
künstliche intelligenz dfk zu pm sagte
er vor fünf oder zehn jahren hätte ich
gesagt lasst die kirche mal im dorf
gucken wir doch erst mal in welche
richtung sich die künstliche intelligenz
entwickelt das ist jetzt anders die
angst geht um was die künstliche
intelligenz angeht und kann noch mehr
das neueste phänomen die fake videos in
denen scheinbar menschen agieren dieses
aber gar nicht sind ki hat hier die
fähigkeit die realität realistisch
nachzubilden alles ist möglich und dass
eben absolut realistisch das spricht
dann mal zum beispiel der ehemalige
amerikanische präsident obama und
manipuliert die zuschauer dann mit
falschaussagen doch kann eben auch gutes
leisten und das sogar in den meisten
anwendungen kann die medizin
revolutionieren wenn wir zum beispiel
tumor diagnosen besser stellen und
therapien besser planen können sagt
antonio krüger zur pnp verfahren seien
auch für den übergang zu
klimafreundlicher energieerzeugung
entscheidend um die schwankungen von
wind und solarstrom in den stromnetzen
auszugleichen
85 prozent der anwendung künstliche
intelligenz sind unproblematisch und wir
glauben an ihr enormes positives
potenzial so eu-strategie kilian groß
zur em als beispiel nennt er den corona
impfstoff der nur dank cani verfahren so
schnell habe entwickelt werden können
der pharmakonzern johnson johnson machte
beispielsweise mit hilfe eines
mathematischen modells orte ausfindig an
denen hohe infektionszahlen zu erwarten
waren und führte dort klinische studien
zu einem vakzin durch kilian groß ist
jurist in der generaldirektion
kommunikationsnetze und technologien der
eu kommission in europa ist er dafür
zuständig die künstliche intelligenz in
die schranken zu weisen sein statement
zur pm wir wollen sicherstellen dass die
entwicklung werte basieren verläuft und
es grenzen gibt es ermöglichten dinge
die wir in europa gar nicht oder nicht
in dieser form haben wollen dinge die
wir innerhalb von demokratie nicht
akzeptabel finden in der eu sollen diese
drei regeln in zukunft für gelten
produkte mit künstlicher intelligenz
sollen grundsätzlich geprüft werden
bevor sie auf den markt kommt so soll
geprüft werden dass sie keine menschen
diskriminiert und auch keine gefahr für
menschen darstellen verboten sind keine
systeme die menschliches verhalten
manipulieren oder behörden ermöglichen
wie beim social scoring bürgerinnen und
bürger zu bewerten verboten ist
gesichtserkennung in echtzeit wie sie in
china praktiziert wird mit eng
umrissenen ausnahmen damit werden auch
in europa die ersten versuche gestoppten
zur klassifizierung von menschen
einzusetzen seit 2018 wird in den
arbeitsämtern österreichs an digitaler
assistent eingesetzt der einschätzen
soll wie sinnvoll es ist arbeitslose zu
fördern sprich nicht nachvollziehbare
algorithmen entscheiden hier über die
zukunft der menschen bevor sich die
arbeitslosen bewähren können entscheidet
die künstliche intelligenz hohe chancen
auf eine neue arbeitsstelle mittlere
chancen niedrige chancen noch
entscheiden die angestellten des
arbeitsamtes final doch das system
wendet social scoring bereits an und
müsste nach den neuen eu richtlinien in
zukunft abgeschaltet werden lebensgefahr
besteht also bei karin noch nicht aber
unser leben kann durch die entscheidung
einer ki nachhaltig verändert werden zu
unserem nachteil und jetzt gibt es diese
die gmk minikleid combo kamera drohne zu
gewinnen 2,7 car video und
stabilisierung auf drei achsen flugzeit
30 minuten zwei kilometer hd video
übertragung sicht sensoren und präzises
schweben mit gps absolut auf see
ar.drone außerdem gibt es dazu auch noch
zwei gratis ausgaben des magazins pm
inklusive der aktuellen ausgabe dafür
einfach gleich hier klicken kleiner
geheimtipp die chancen zu gewinnen sind
nicht so ganz schlecht und in der
aktuellen ausgabe gibt es noch viel mehr
wo es zur künstlichen intelligenz und
noch viele weitere super interessante
themen aus der wissenschaft und
forschung zum beispiel berichtet gm über
das unglaubliche james webb
weltraumteleskop das noch dieses jahr in
den weltraum startet über die ziemlich
verrückte entstehung der alpen oder über
den tod als lebensspender kadaver sind
nämlich ziemlich wichtig für die natur
ich drücke euch jedenfalls die daumen
hier klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran